100 euro sind 104 schweizer franken 2400
ps 12.000 yen oder 1,6 millionen
indonesische rupiah das geld ist überall
auf der welt unterschiedlich viel wert
um die kaufkraft schwankt stark aber was
bekommt man eigentlich real für sein
geld wie weit bringen 100 euro in
thailand oder indien russland oder japan
island oder den vereinigten staaten von
amerika um das herauszufinden machen wir
uns in diesem neuen format auf eine
reise um die welt und wir starten in new
york city viel spaß mit der ersten folge
von 100 euro in der stadt die niemals
schläft bevor wir aber geld ausgeben
können brauchen wir erstmal geld denn
mit euros bezahlen geht natürlich nicht
überauchen dollar
umgerechnet sind unsere 100 euro circa
115 dollar und das wird wahrscheinlich
eine sache die am beeindruckendsten ist
in dieser serie zu sehen wie viel wir in
der fremdwährung für unsere euros
bekommt 115 dollar fühlt sich zumindest
so an als hätten wir gerade geld
verdient werde ich dass er geld
abgehoben haben warum zur hölle macht es
aber nur sinn dass wir mit dieser serie
genau in new york starten und nicht
irgendwo anders zweimal im jahr werden
die lebenshaltungskosten der wichtigsten
städte der welt von economist
intelligence unit in einer studie
verglichen es werden preise von 160
verschiedenen artikeln in den
verschiedenen städten verglichen um dann
ein ranking der städte aufzustellen wie
viel geld wird verdient wie viel ist die
währung wert wie viel kosten produkte
und so weiter der basiswert dieser
studie welche mit 100 angegeben wird ist
seit jahren new york city und genau
deswegen sind wir quasi gezwungen genau
hier zu starten ok 100 euro scheint
ziemlich viel geld für einen tag aber
ist es in new york auch eine menge geld
neben dem ganzen turek rahmen der
unterhaltung und so weiter müssen wir
auch natürlich unsere ganz normalen
bedürfnisse stellen das bedeutet essen
schlafen einkaufen und so weiter und
genau das schauen wir uns als
allererstes an damit wir gut gestärkt in
dieses video starten können deswegen
habe ich mich auf die suche gemacht nach
einem möglichst günstigen frühstück und
auf etwas gestoßen das vermutlich in new
york ein bisschen kultstatus hat denn
ich bin schon da und es ist eine
schlange vor dem laden
[Musik]
von david
denk
und vielleicht most oder track
[Musik]
ein wirklich kleiner laden vielleicht
schon mittlerweile ein bisschen turi
maze gewann aber trotzdem hat es sich
sehr gut angefühlt es war übels
vertrauen das essen hat richtig gut
geschmeckt das ganze hat 15 dollar
gekostet das bedeutet so viel bleibt
jetzt noch übrig warte mal der hatte
doch irgendwas von 13 dollar gesagt
beruhen wieso haben wir jetzt 15 dollar
abgerechnet in new york oder allgemein
in amerika zahlt man nie den preis der
angeschlagen ist es kommen immer noch
gebühren mit drauf egal ob es irgendeine
steuer oder ein tipp oder irgendwas ist
man bezahlt nie das was auf dem menü
steht zwei euro waren tipp deswegen
glatt 15 dollar und jetzt heißt es new
york weiter erleben eine sache die super
entscheidend ist wie wir durch die stadt
kommen da gibt es eigentlich zwei
optionen u-bahn und citybikes ein
wochenplan für die u bahn kostet 35
dollar citybike 15 euro am tag so lange
und so oft wie wir wollen ich glaube das
ist die beste option auch wenn die
u-bahn irgendwie zum new york gehört
werde ich mich früher citibank
entscheiden die fahrräder stehen
eigentlich überall rum man kann die
nicht überall abstellen wie so leim oder
so aber es gibt eigentlich an jeder ecke
so einen dieser standorte wo man sich
die räder leihen kann und so eins werde
ich mir jetzt buchen
der ist fühlt sich so krank anja und so
fahre ich jetzt durch die stadt zusammen
getan und bin super schnell überall wo
ich sein aber man muss natürlich auch
die pedalen treten klar die u-bahn wer
günstiger gewesen aber wir bekommen
einfach viel mehr von der stadt und dem
richtigen gefühl der stadt mit wenn wir
auf dem fahrrad unterwegs sind der
verkehr die großen gebäude all das
würden wir natürlich nicht sehen wenn
wir unter der erde fahren
gerade nochmal gut gedanken und genau
für solche unvorhersehbaren situationen
ist es wichtig richtig versichert zu
sein und hier und plugins
ist ein kostenloser versicherungsmanager
der 100 prozent unabhängig und kostenlos
für euch genau die richtigen
versicherung aber nicht nur darf schlag
hilft euch auf eure bestehenden
versicherungen zu optimieren dafür gibt
es ein glas sekt nämlich genau sagt wo
ich vielleicht noch nicht richtig sicher
zeit oder volver sparen können und das
ganze natürlich bevor es zu spät ist
wenn das aber immer noch nicht reicht
gibt es ein expertenteam das euch
komplett kostenlos berät bei super
speziellen versicherungsangelegenheiten
oder wenn ihr einfach irgendwie nicht
richtig weiter wisst oder was du über
spezielles versichern müssten lag es in
deutschland und österreich verfügbar und
ihr bekommt als neukunde mit dem coach
dave wall caps bis zu 45 euro amazon
gutschein wenn die drei euro bestehenden
versicherungen programm 15 euro ebenso
bestehende versicherungen die hochladen
und ich bin super dankbar das nicht
klappt mittlerweile zum vierten oder
fünften mal unterstützt und es möglich
macht dass ich solche videos für euch
machen kann vielen dank und viel spaß
weiter mit dem video
nachdem ich gerade zwei minuten planlos
einfach drauflos gefahren bin bin ich
scheinbar am treff score angekommen und
ich glaube genau deswegen ist das
fahrrad die richtige entscheidung
[Applaus]
irgendwann kommt ich habe viel werbung
aufgehängt hier aber das braucht noch
ein bisschen planung und ein bisschen
geld
weg vom times square ich habe mir die
finger wund gesucht nach einer
möglichkeit günstig und für unter 100
dollar irgendwo zu übernachten damit ich
noch geld habe was ich heute ausgeben
kann es gab kein hostel kein hotel gar
nichts in der nähe von new york womit
ich noch irgendwie geld übrig gehabt
hätte um über den tag zu kommen deswegen
musste ich schwere geschütze auffahren
und habe in meiner story gefragt ob ich
bei hängematten schlafen kann der in new
york und unglücklicherweise hat jemand
gemeldet und die wohnung schauen uns
jetzt an ich glaube irgendwo in einem
dieser häuser müsste es sein und das
wird mein platz heute nach 405 genau
hier meister ich bin unten super alter
ich bin richtig gespannt eine sache die
ich völlig verrückt finde ich bin zwei
minuten vom times square zu fuß weg
gegangen und plötzlich ist die
totenstille hier ist nichts da vorne
übelsten übels viele leute die einen
anlagen und so hier ist einfach ruhe
hier wohnen leute hier ist einfach ruhe
das ist simon er ist mit zwei freunden
für ein auslandssemester nach amerika
gefahren und sie lassen mich
freundlicherweise bei ihnen in der
wohnung über nacht kuss ich bin in der
wohnung angekommen in der ich heute für
eine nacht bleiben und ihr werdet noch
in einem vollen video sehen wie die
gesamte wohnung aussieht aber das hier
ist der bereich mein bereich für heute
nachdem ich kostenlos übernachten kann
denn es gibt definitiv keine möglichkeit
für unter 100 euro wenn du ja auch zu
schlafen geschweige denn in new york
eine bleibe zu finden wo ich dann noch
geld habe weil sie über den tag ausgeben
kann ach was irgendein hostels zuschauer
finden können nein tatsächlich nicht das
günstigste hostel in der nacht wo ich
dieses video gedreht habe hat 98 dollar
gekostet mit fünf anderen leuten in
einem raum 98 dollar deswegen bin ich
super happy hier schlafen zu können und
das gesamte video der wohnung kommt in
den nächsten wochen
nach dem ganzen in der stadt rumrennen
wohnung anschauen am time square gewesen
bin ich wieder ziemlich hungrig geworden
und deswegen gehen wir nicht in dieser
aus sondern zu one dollar pizza direkt
hinter diesem bus befindet sich von
dollar pizza ich möchte seit jahren
dahin nachdem ich bei caseking ist immer
mal wieder raus davon gesehen habe in
new york eine instanz 99 cent bezahlt
man für ein stück pizza und genau da
gebe es mittagessen
zwei dollar 75 für zwei stücke pizza und
eine dose mount und jugend mehr amerika
geht nicht ich bin rechts kommt dass in
dieser kulisse jetzt zu essen ein
jahrelanger traum und das ist kein witz
ich bin gerade beim rad auf dem weg zum
central park und mir ist aufgefallen
meine liste ist voll mit sachen die ich
noch kostenlos machen kann und mein geld
gebnis mehr als ich meinen besser ist es
aber im prinzip die stadt zu erleben und
alle wichtigen sachen gesehen zu haben
kostet 0 cent man braucht das rad 15
euro und ansonsten sind die besten
sachen for free dann ist kommen noch
richtig krasse sachen
central park komplett kostenlos es ist
herbst muss ich dazu noch sagen
absolutes must see
[Musik]
wir sind heute wirklich einmal komplett
quer durch new york das hier ist der
aktuelle stand und als wäre das nicht
genug fahren wir jetzt kostenlos mit der
staten island ferry einmal von new york
raus und können uns die skyline vom
wasser anschauen
ihr könnt es euch zwar nicht vorstellen
aber ich war unglaublich fertig von dem
tag super viel erlebt super viel los
eine menge eindrücke und ich war richtig
fertig vielleicht liegt es auch daran
dass ich überall mein fahrrad
hingefahren bin aber ich hatte einfach
keine kraft mehr zu moderieren und habe
einfach nur die aussicht genossen
absolute zehn von zehn komplett
kostenlos und so nah kommt man
eigentlich nicht an die freiheitsstatue
ran wenn man in der stadt ist man
einfach nur umgeben von riesigen
erdrückenden gebäuden und so hat man mal
die möglichkeit rauszukommen sich das
ganze von außen anzuschauen das wasser
plätschern zuhören und einfach die ruhe
alles schön und gut aber die tu dollar
pizza ist jetzt auch schon wieder sechs
stunden her wir müssen essen gehen und
nachdem ich mich beim frühstück und beim
mittagessen für fastfood entschieden
hatte dachte ich ich müsste endlich mal
hochqualitativ essen gehen und das kann
in new york so einiges kosten für eine
pizza mit büffelmozzarella ein großes
bier und eine cola habe ich geschlagene
45 dollar bezahlt und das ist nicht mal
besonders viel in new york das ist
eigentlich ziemlich basics und absoluter
standard preis wenn man essen geht von
dort aus mit dem fahrrad wieder hoch zu
hell's kitchen ein bezirk in new york in
dem die wohnung steht in der ich in
dieser nacht kostenlos schlafen werde
ich wollte aber noch nicht schlafen und
habe mich deswegen mit lin anton und
simon meinen freundlichen gastgebern für
diese nacht auf ein bier aber nicht
irgendwo sondern in rudis bar and grill
einer der wenigen standorte in new york
wo man für verhältnismäßig vernünftiges
geld bier trinken kann ein einzelnes
glas für drei und eine pizza für zwölf
dollar ist ein absolut fairer preis und
nicht zu vergleichen mit den normalen
preisen wo man schon mal ziemlich
schnell zehn dollar für ein bier
bezahlen was die sache aber noch viel
besser macht für drei euro bekommt man
nicht nur ein bier sondern auch hot dogs
wenn man aber eine pizza kauft und sich
dazu noch ganz gut mit dem barmann
versteht kann es schon mal sein dass man
einfach so viele hotdogs essen kann wie
man will um vernünftig auf die nacht
vorbereitet zu sein bin ich nach der
bahn noch mal in einen normalen
einkaufsladen gegangen habe mir einen
gate array eine große flasche wasser und
eine zahnbürste gekauft so sage und
schreibe 13 donner unglaublich
unverschämt aber tatsächlich sind
lebensmittel und allgemeinen sachen die
man zum alltäglichen leben braucht in
new york einfach zu teuer also wirklich
völlig verrückt teuer dann selber
schlafen gegangen und ich hatte endlich
mal zeit die ganzen eindrücke von dem
tag auf mich wirken zu lassen eine sache
ist mir dabei besonders aufgefallen ich
war super zufrieden wie ich die 100 euro
an diesem tag ausgereizt habe aber
gemerkt viele der sachen die wirklich
extrem werden wo man die stadt noch mal
ein bisschen krasser erleben könnte sind
einfach so teuer dass sie aus dem 100
euro budget ausfall deswegen habe ich
direkt ein zweites format angefangen was
sich auch in allen anderen städten noch
fortführen werde an dem ich 1000 euro an
einem tag ausgeben um in diesen städten
quasi alles kaufen und erledigt können
was sie schon immer mal machen wollte
das kommt in den nächsten monaten und es
war unglaublich
fazit new york ist fucking teuer wenn
man aber ein bisschen darauf achtet was
man macht wo man schläft und was man
konsumiert kann man tatsächlich
eigentlich verliebt davonkommen es ist
wichtig die richtigen leute um sich
herum zu haben die einem sagen können wo
man hingehen soll und wo man es besser
sein lässt new york lebt aber davon auch
einfach new york zu sein und hat ebenso
sachen wie in central park oder in
staten island ferry und im prinzip waren
dass die sachen die den tag für mich
ausgesucht ich bin absolut auf dieses
format werde in den nächsten wochen in
tokio istanbul und super vielen anderen
städten seien vergesse ich den kanal zu
abonnieren um das nicht zu verpassen und
wir sehen uns am donnerstag wieder
[Musik]